皆は最近、運動はしてるかい？
俺は・・・してないよ？
と言う訳で僕は最近メチャクチャ運動はしてない訳なんですよ
もう！一年ぐらい運動はしてなくて
最近ホントに体の衰えが本当に感じられてきて非情にヤバい
すぐ疲れるんですよ、何かしてても
さすがにちょっと マズイ と思って来たんで
今日は、家でもできる運動をしようと思います。
皆はポールダンスって知ってます？ポールダンス
俺はね、何かで、テレビとかで見たことはあるよ？
こう、ポールがあるんですけども、
ポールに、なんか女の人が
こうやってなんか・・・
わかるっしょ？
こうね？
セクシーなヤツがあるんですよ、ポールダンスって言う、こう
なんか  あるんですよ、ポールダンスって言うこうなんか
ポールに、こうやって何か、こう色々するやつがあるんですよ
今日は実際にポールダンスを家でやるために
突っ張り棒を準備しました
オーッとっと、ヤメロヤメロ、また失敗するだろとかって言うなって、な？
今度は失敗しないゾ？
今までの突っ張り棒は、重力を感じてた
今回は重力じゃない。今回はメチャクチャ長いやつを準備したので、
今回はね、重力は  カンケーネー。上と下を止めればいいだけだ
今回はもう、確実に成功させますよ？
俺はポールダンス家で絶対するから
なんか突っ張り棒をしちゃうと  絶対失敗するみたいな  イメージがあるんですけども
今回は違いますよ？　今回は重力を使わないからね？
しっかり締めれば確実にポールダンスが出来るはずです
今までの事があるからかなり強めにしときます
去年はなんか突っ張り棒で一世をふうびしたからさ
たまには初心に帰って、突っ張り棒っすよ
完璧です
先ずポールダンスってやったことないから何から始めていいかわかんない
何か、こういう感じでしょ？　なんか
ポールダンス関係ないわ
ポールでなんかするんだよな？
こうゆう事をするんだよ、確か
いえーす。あ、いえーす。
ポール　イエース
ぽーる